mood follows action  you scroll through instagram you see the  inspiring quote you listen to the  podcast you read the book or you  you you know read the summary of the  book and then you feel  like you've accomplished something there  is a little bit of a dopamine release  with that like oh this was a an  esteemable act on behalf of myself i've  done the work  why is my life any better you know and  oh well it must be because there's this  new book that came out this week or this  other podcast that i haven't listened to  at this point the information is all out  there you know and then it becomes on  you as to whether you start practicing  it  and really getting honest with yourself  and modifying some of your behavior  patterns that are leading you astray